we in America are immigrants or the
children of immigrants we are one people
but a people welded from many nations
and races my name is Michelle and my
family came from Scotland to Canada in
1824 and then in the 1920s they
emigrated to the US great
great-grandfather came to the u.s. from
China in the late 1800s and worked on
the Pacific Railroad the Ukraine and
Poland and they came to the States in
the 89 emily's from Casta lamar in italy
and came here around 1910 then there are
families like this who have suffered a
religious persecution that could drive
them from their homes they emigrated to
America after surviving separate
concentration camps in 1946 and my mom
immigrated from Seoul Korea in 1968 to
the man deprived of civil rights in his
native land America offers the hope of
freedom my parents and I traveled to the
United States after the Vietnam War from
a Thai refugee camp my mom's came here
from Nicaragua in 1979 just before the
revolution broke out my father side of
the family came here by force they're
descendants of slaves and my mother's
side of the family came here by choice
as immigrants my dad is from Trinidad
and my mom is from Guyana and then moved
here in their late 20s and there are
those who have known it firsthand the
political oppression of autocratic
government and I was born in Jalalabad
Afghanistan and I came to America with
my family in 1982 Russia had invaded
Afghanistan at the time and millions of
Afghans fled the country my parents are
from northern Iraq and my parents came
to the u.s. in 1984 everything was going
well until the revolution came then
everything turned into chaos my family
from Iran to Tampa Florida in 1987 my
mom came to America from Ireland in 1987
my parents migrated to Seattle
Washington from marijuana quato about 30
years my parents immigrated to this
country in 1989 from Bangladesh Emily
and I moved to America from Russia in
the early 90s my family is from India I
came to the United States about ten
years ago my mom my dad myself and my
siblings we all moved here about ten
years ago when I was 16 from Iran
millions of every nation and calling
drawn together by their vision of
America a vision of land opportunity and
freedom I don't know how my story is any
different than the Irish and the Germans
and the Polish and Scottish she came to
America and did absolutely amazing
things sides of the family are patriots
they love this country they've worked
very hard for this country so in my
opinion doesn't really matter how they
got here but why they see
[Music]
Wow